الهدوء عاده تدريجيا الى البرازيل اثرى
مشهد اندراميا غير مسبوق في تاريخ
الديمقراطيه البرازيليه وعلى الفور بدات
السلطات التحقيق في اسوا هجوم شعبي على
مؤسسات الدوله
القصه بدات اجتياح عشرات الالاف من انصار
الرئيس البرازيلي اليمني السابق جير
بورسونارو قلب العاصمه بعد اسبوع واحد فقط
من تنصيبه
رئيسا للبلاد
وارتدى المحتاجون قمصان منتخب كره القدم
وحمل واعلام البرازيل قبل اقتحامهم مراكز
الحكم الثلاثه الكونجرس والمحكمه العليا
كما حاصلوا القصر الرئاسي في العاصمه قبل
اقتحامه والعبث بمقتنياته وبعد ساعات طردت
الشرطه المحتاجين من مؤسسات الدوله
واعتقلت العشرات منهم
تلك التطورات دفعت بالرئيس الجديد الى وصف
الاحتجاجات بالانقلاب كما فرض اجراءات
الاستثنائيه لاستعاده النظام
الذي تولى منصبه في الاول من يناير حمل
الرئيس السابق بورسونارو مسؤوليه الاحداث
باثارته حمله وصفها بالمزومه بشان تزوير
الانتخابات
بدوره ومن فلوريدا الامريكيه التي وصلها
قبل يومين من انتهاء فتره رئاسه رفض
بورسونال ووصف المظاهرات بانها سلميه
الديمقراطيه لكنه اعتبر ان اقتحام المباني
الحكوميه يمثل تجاوزا احدث لاقت ردود فعل
عالميه ممدده اعتبرتها تهديدا للديمقراطيه
كما احيت بتفاصيلها ما حدث في واشنطن قبل
عامين يوم اقتحم الانصار الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب مبنى الكونجرس حنان
المصري العربي